thank you appreciate that
well good evening everybody how's
everyone doing tonight
gotta say Jimmy a spectacular event
really
um I have found it so inspiring and so
stimulating to speculate and explore the
ways in which Sound and Music can crack
Us open because that that's how the
light gets in right
um so a little bit about me my name is
uh Jason Silva and I've spent the last
decade uh traveling the world and
speaking about technology and creativity
and Innovation and the future of
humanity I I'm very much a dreamer and
an optimist and really my career took
off because of these videos that I used
to make about our sort of
technological science fiction utopian
future and my passion for technology
really was born out of this idea that
through technology we were able to
transcend our limitations through
technology we were able to overcome all
the ways in which we were bounded and in
which we were finite I mean it really
began for me as an adolescent having an
existential crisis about mortality I
read a book called the denial of death
the book by Ernest Becker Pulitzer Prize
winning book I highly recommend that
basically said that the worm at the core
of the human condition that the thing
that makes us anxious the faint disquiet
is our unique awareness of our mortality
in the words of Sheldon Solomon the in
the explicit awareness that you're a
breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die and ultimately no more
significant than a lizard or a potato is
not especially uplifting
and so you know I read this book the
denial of death I remember another line
from the book that I want to share with
you he says that the the idea of the
human animal is that to have emerged
from nothing to have come from nothing
to have a name to have consciousness of
self to have deep inner meaning and
excruciating inner yearning for life and
self-expression and with all this yet to
die I mean this is was that the primary
idea was that the source of our unease
and our dis-ease was that we had this
this boundless symbolic in her life but
then we were bounded by this finite
aging to decaying body this heart
pumping breath gasping decaying body so
we were sort of simultaneously gods and
worms all at once and so for me
discovering technology was a pathway to
Transcendence that technology was a
pathway to Salvation you know I became a
kind of follower of the Techno religion
known as The Singularity and this idea
that through technology we would
overcome human limitations of all sorts
and and in many ways we have triumphed
one of the most interesting things about
technology is that it seems to progress
at an exponential rate which is sort of
counterintuitive because we tend to
think about change in a linear rate but
but technology changes exponentially you
know the smartphone that you have in
your pocket today is a million times
cheaper a million times smaller and a
thousand times more powerful than what
used to be a 60 million dollar
supercomputer that was half a building
in size 40 years ago I mean that's the
kind of astounding technological
progress that we've been privy to you
know like we have this unique capacity
to to shrink the lag time between what
we can image imagine what we can create
you know the Psychedelic philosopher
Terence McKenna he calls us the the
coral reef-like animal the extruder of
technological material that we take in
matter of low organization we put it
through the filters of the human mind
and we extrude space shuttles and
iPhones and so for me this was it this
was the pathway to Salvation we've
doubled the human lifespan we're getting
more advanced medicine every day we're
doing technologically mediated telepathy
we can communicate across time and space
you know geography has collapsed I mean
we we are building this world shaped by
imagination powered by technology and
the sky's the limit
except it's not
so the last 10 years have been for me
this again this techno-utopianism this
marveling at our astounding capacity for
Progress exponential Technologies and
fully realizing our imagination it's
what I've come to realize increasingly
in the words of Edward O Wilson is that
no matter how Godlike our Technologies
are we still have
Paleolithic brains and we still have
medieval laws and so and so we lack the
systems and we lack the wisdom to deploy
these Technologies in order to address
the grand challenges of humanity right
we've never had such abundance right we
we fly airplanes across the sky we share
our thoughts and ideas across the planet
we have cognitized the world electrified
the world I mean we are as Gods if our
ancestors could look at us they'd think
we are gods and yet simultaneously we're
living through a crisis of alienation a
mental health crisis that is putting us
on our knees according to the World
Health Organization more people die by
Suicide now than from natural disasters
and armed conflict combined and so even
though we have iPhones and airplanes
that fly and and we're you know about to
like go back to the moon like even
though we have all of this we are
suffering from these diseases of Despair
these diseases of alienation these
diseases of ruminations you know like we
we've become Our Own Worst Enemy these
self-defeating thought patterns that
have infected us have made us blind to
our genius and blind to our own capacity
to transcend any and all of our
limitations and so we're living in the
best of all possible worlds and in the
worst of all possible worlds and so
after a decade especially speaking to
corporate audiences about exponential
Technologies I feel like we need to also
talk about these two other things that
aren't being addressed with the with the
ferocity that they need to be addressed
which is again we have Paleolithic
brains we have medieval laws and then we
have these god-like Technologies and so
it has sent me on a kind of journey into
the world of psychedelic healing and
transformation and that's why I call
these remarks this this era that I
believe we should be heading into the
cyberdelic age an age of virtual
realities and programmable biologies and
psychoactive Technologies and so what
interests me is how do we use all of
these three these these three tracks
these three things like how do we use
like virtual reality and digital
technology and how do we use like
biohacking and programmable biology and
how do we use psychoactive Technologies
to really like engage the technical
material of human subjectivity itself as
Eric Davis has written like how do we
get in there and like rewrite the the oh
us like rewrite the inner narrative like
how do we move past our fractures and
how do we render ourselves whole and
then as Jamie wheel said maybe even
render ourselves holy so I have a couple
of videos that I want to show you today
that try to map some of these ideas as
I've explored them through my work and
so and so the first video
is about the nature of trauma the nature
of like as as they say the body keeps
the score and how like experiences that
we have in our lives they they really
kind of like you know our cells are a
technology that turns experience into
biology and so how trauma lives in the
body and how and how PTSD can only
really be resolved through its inverse
inverse PTSD so it's about the the
intensity of the intervention that is
needed to heal the places in which we
are fractured so if you can play the the
first video please
you know life throws you punches and
disjointment follows the fractures of
trauma are such that we experience a
Schism and we become
frightened even of ourselves we're no
longer safe in our own bodies and what
this does is it casts a shadow Upon Our
experience of the world we bring this
trauma to the doorstep of every moment
and so we become afraid the world
becomes hostile and this this dark cloud
of trauma that kind of colors our
windshield becomes our interpretive
framework it becomes our lens of
perception and as Chris lethubby wrote
we see through our lenses and we see
with our lenses but we don't see the
lenses themselves and so that scary
world we're seeing through our lenses is
being shaped and informed and colored by
that lens but we don't realize that
anymore we've come to believe that the
lens is reality that the map is the
territory but this corrupted lens and
this corrupted map that's been that's
been severed and disjointed that's
experienced a Schism of trauma the rape
the transgression the violation that has
brought us into disjointment disc
congruence this is now coloring our
world the body keeps the score we bring
this gnawing anxiety and
self-consciousness with us to the
doorstep of every moment it's temporal
dislocation that's what David David
lensen calls it and in this temporal
dislocation we over determine the
present moment we misread the present
moment and so we're walking on eggshells
unnecessarily a victim of our own
self-defeating projections and we need
to break through this we need to break
past this to come back into wholeness
and so that map of the world that lens
of perception has to die we have to have
an experience that is akin to inverse
PTSD right an experience that is as
intense as the trauma was but it's
inverse so what that does is it bumps us
up a level and now we can see the lenses
that we see through and with we can
actually see the lenses themselves and
once we see the lenses we can dispense
with those lenses and that means we
become twice born and now we meet the
world not with fear perhaps but with
curiosity and Grace and Equanimity
something has shifted from the inside
out and then everything changes right
and so that's what we're all after that
kind of healing that kind of reconciling
from disjointment to coming into
congruence coming into Integrity or
coming into acceptance and coming into
wholeness we need to integrate all of us
and come back into that place we need to
reconcile we need positive catharsis
so you know one of the things that I uh
that I was talking about in that video
was a theory put out by a guy called
Chris letheby I really recommend you
look up his work he talks about the
difference between knowledge by
description and knowledge by
acquaintance you know when a person is
in the midst of a mental health crisis
when they're in the pits of Despair or
anxiety or rumination you know they're
they're crushing depression they don't
they can't get out of bed there's a
failure of the imagination according to
Kierkegaard where the people the person
can't actually imagine a world outside
of their distress they can't actually
they don't they can't literally summon a
vision of what it's like not to be
depressed so let's say they're in this
shitty life situation there's no way out
there you can't just talk them through a
new possibility you can't tell them what
it's like to go into waterfalls in
Iceland you know like you have to go
there to to know there and what seems to
be so powerful about using psychedelics
and probably combined in the right
sentence setting with the right music is
that it gives people this experience of
knowledge by acquaintance they become
directly acquainted with the felt
reality of direct experience it puts
them there it gives them another place
to plant their feet it's this idea of
bumping up a level that he talks about
right and so these these interpretive
Frameworks these lenses of perception
that you see through and you see with
now you can see the lenses it's like
that metacognition that the previous
speaker was talking about and from that
place there can be real transformation
and real intervention and often you know
the other trapping that the previous
speaker mentioned is how do you avoid
spiritual ego how do you avoid the the
Messiah like feeling that now you know
the answer well a lot of what happens in
psychedelic spaces when people are
healing when people are potentially
glimpsing wisdom
is there these experiences are are
ineffable and they seem to be Beyond
language again you have to go there to
know there but people are creatures of
language they want to be able to like
put the experience into a box and say
like I'm Healed because of this and so
there's a tendency to grab what I think
is an experience of like Poetic truth
and literalize it and I also think
that's a mistake you know the minute you
try to take what is your truth or your
poetic truth your poetry and turn it
into scripture that other people now
need to listen to that's the beginning
of spiritual ego that's the beginning of
that trap and so I've always felt that
what happens in psychedelics is about
poetry and and it is ineffable and it
really can only be rendered in the
language in the elastic language of
poetry and that's what this next video
is about it sort of gives a little bit
of a taste of what a mystical experience
is like what these kinds of
interventions these psychoactive
interventions can do to our psyches and
it's inspired by the ideas of Auto rank
in his book called the idea of the Holy
so what happens when we see the holy and
how do we how do we experience the holy
grounded in ourselves in a kind of
poetic truth that doesn't like you know
turn us into spiritual egotists let's
play it all of a sudden this this
recontextualization in this reframing
and this beholding of oneself as a
conduit in a larger hole from which
molecules and meanings flow is to bask
in the mystery is to bask in the
mysterium tremendous Auto rank in his
book The idea of the Holy wrote about
the nature of these religious
experiences and these encounters with
the mystery that repels and the Mystery
that attracts or the kind of sublime
encounter with ineffability with
something faster than we are but
something also far more beautiful and
benign and benevolent and omnipotent and
so these these dances with Starlight
these moments of holding this larger
vastness this moment of reconciliation
and reinterpretation of one of what we
are
kind of Enlightenment right we undergo
an Enlightenment and an expansion once
the the idea of what we are dies the the
birth of what we really are comes into
awareness he who must save his life must
first lose it and and I guess we could
only hope that more people have these
experiences beholding nature in a deep
enough way that a shift transpires that
rewires their nervous system reframes
their perspectives re-channels what they
see revivifies who they think they are
and then in turn changes their actions
in the world may we all rise together
into the light and Steward our
environment protect our environment
Marvel at our environment worship our
environment and truly come back into the
Garden of Eden and that's the kind of
ecodelic Consciousness that I'm
interested in may we all wake ourselves
up and then Steward ourselves and this
planet back into the light right for we
are Starlight right like our atoms were
cooked in the furnaces of stars and so
the idea of Us coming to see ourselves
in this way seeing ourselves as
self-organizing assemblages of atoms
cooked in the dying stars and getting to
participate in an evolutionary process
of such unfathomable complexity this
teleological self-organizing self-riding
self-authoring songstress you know this
this theater this this Carnival of like
engendering complexity that mutates and
explodes in every direction this
intelligence explosion this creative
explosion this explosion of complexity
in every direction we can participate in
it as we behold it and as we watch it we
can be in the thralls of it while we are
stewards of it all at the same time we
all wait for the cosmos to know itself
and we are a way for this for we are a
way to sing the songs that orchestrate
the universe and to that end that's our
responsibility to be the mouthpieces and
the stewards of this of this realization
this Revelation you know this this
singularity 30 and it's a lot of beauty
to Fathom it's a it's a lot of beauty to
Fathom but that's our responsibility
that's what we're here to do to be these
marvelous conduits these marvelous
conduits in a Timeless hole
what a dance right to to just grab our
seat for the game of the Millennium man
what a gift what a gift what a gift
obviously I was kind of tripping balls
towards the end there
[Applause]
no no
no no but uh
by the way it was the audio of the
videos could you hear it in the back is
that all right yeah
you know it's interesting though because
again like I use I use art you know and
that's that's visual music you know I
think film Like Music In the words of
Gene Youngblood reflects humankind's
historical drive to manifest our
Consciousness outside of our mind in
front of our eyes or within our ears you
know music is proof the human race is
greater than it knows without music life
would be a mistake or as Jamie Wheels
said music is the wallpaper of the mind
and so you know again like like I fell
in love with human Ingenuity with with
our technological proficiency and our
technological capacity because I saw it
you know and I'm quoting this wonderful
book about the Wachowski Brothers the
director the Wachowski sisters now the
directors of the Matrix when when when
they said that that they believed that
the imagination can increase
increasingly summon its own
literalization you know like that the
imagination is summoning its own
literalization that's how I've always
seen technology or as Ray Kurzweil said
our capacity to imagine which a virtual
realities in our Mind's Eye combined
with our modest looking thumbs was
sufficient to usher in this secondary
force of evolution called technology and
it will continue until the entire
universe is at our fingertips like it's
all great but if we don't get wise you
know like Stuart brand said we are as
gods and might as well get good at it
how do we become better Gods you know
how do we become better gods and that's
where I really think that the role of
Music the role of film the role of
psychedelics to craft better myths to
give us better encounters with the
mysterium tremendum to recontextualize
the self and see ourselves as a
marvelous conduit in a Timeless whole
from which molecules and meanings flow
from neurons to nebula and back again
like we need to give ourselves that
existential reframing so that we can
like show up and grow up and finally
free the brave Reckless Gods within us
all as D.H Lawrence wrote Because that's
our potential I mean that is our
potential and it's so frustrating to me
when I see the petty petty ways and the
petty things that we allow to hold us
back you know our neuroticism our
rumination these diseases of Despair
these diseases of meaning well it's like
we need better stories to enrich us with
deeper meanings and in some in some
cases the greatest story is the story of
that mind-expanding trip that
psychedelic intervention that finally
gets you past your resistances and
reframes the world for you and imbues
the world with magic once more you know
Aldous Huxley had this great line and
doors of perception when he said that
when the mescaline kicked in he was no
longer looking at an unusual flower
arrangement but instead he was seeing
what Adam had seen on the morning of his
creation the miracle moment by moment of
naked existence and so how do we reframe
our minds with to get to meet the world
with that virginal noticing how do we
deliberately deploy things like music
and intention and the right language
because words aren't just descriptive
they're also generative to change our
very subjectivity and re-enchant the
world right because the world is full of
magic things patiently waiting for our
senses to grow sharper as Yates wrote
who said the other world is this world
rightly seen and so in my in my videos
I'm not just trying to like explain this
kind of stuff I'm trying to evoke it you
know that's what an artist is trying to
do with his work with the right song
with the right music with the right film
we're trying to like evoke and
experience in people we have to people
if it's possible to give people that
knowledge by acquaintance you know can't
dose you guys all with psychedelics but
I can show you these videos to paint a
vision that's inviting you to go hey
look at here come with me and you'll see
it's a world of Pure Imagination as
Willy Wonka said so so this next this
next video is about that it's about
magical realism versus naive realism and
it was inspired by a line from the
British philosopher Alan de Boton you
know Alan de Paton has this great line
and he kind of like divides objective
truth and subjective truth kind of like
separating church and state it's a
pretty good thing you know or Ursula Le
Guin who says science describes
accurately from the outside poetry
describes accurately from the inside
science explicates but poetry implicates
and so what Alan debutton said he said a
journalist maybe more accurate in
describing the details of reality than a
poet but a poet May nevertheless real
truth of a deeper sort beyond the
literal grid and not just a poet but a
musician and a filmmaker and a sound
engineer right it's it's about revealing
the truth beyond the literal grid which
is just as true because we're gods and
worms we're both right we're Eternal
Timeless Spiritual Beings who are you
know aging every single day at the same
time so this video is about orienting
ourselves around the magic that is right
in front of us please show the third
video if you know me no doubt buy now
you are aware that I have a soft spot in
my heart for Magical realism for Magical
realism as a way of being that goes
beyond mere naive realism naive realism
is the transactional realm it's the
quotidian and the everyday it is the
banality and arrogance of the binders
and seeing thats of the adult mind and I
have freed myself
friends I have freed myself from
I forgotten
oh I have freed myself from this naive
realism because instead friends I have
figured out the protocols and procedures
for booting up a new semiotic Universe
for booting up a kind of magical realism
a theater of the Absurd a kind of
aesthetic realm that I can dwell in
awaken dream where I create and perceive
my world I am speaking to you about
deploying a poetic Consciousness about
spraying the world with effervescence
about Awakening the lethargy of custom
and the film of familiarity and
redirecting it instead towards the
wonders of existence I have figured out
friends how to literally live in a realm
of magical realism I am not exaggerating
when I say to you I know how to
italicize perception I know how to set
the world to music I know how to
re-enchant
continuously my field of awareness I
literally live in a poem of my own
choosing and this kind of magical
realism is akin to turning your life
into a work of art to thinking of your
life like a living film we are living
Cinema time becomes liquid upon this
realization that you can enchant and
paint the world with mind that you can
author stories that you can live in a
story world of your own making magical
realism can be more real than mere naive
realism in all of its banality it is
like when Alan de Boton talks about the
difference between a poet and a
journalist you know the quotidian and
the miraculous he says a journalist
maybe more accurate describing the
details of an event than a poet but it
may nevertheless reveal truth of a
deeper sort beyond the literal grid so
when I speak about magical realism I
speak about Realms beyond the literal
grid magical realism is beyond the
literal grid it is beyond the naivete of
cynics the naivete of of of the brooding
resignation of fatalists and nihilists
they've missed the plot they've lost the
through Line This naive realism that
over materializes that over simplifies
that robs the world of all of its poetry
is such poverty and such ignorance
friends because they are not awake they
are asleep but those of us that realize
that the world is made out of Pure
Imagination can drape the cosmos with
story and song and we can sing the songs
that orchestrate the universe and space
and time and mind can collapse into each
other as time becomes liquid and we
become Cinema we've stopped trying to
make art and we have become art like
Samurai's or the Karate Kid we get into
position and we cue the song
I have moved from an Ordinary World
because the world is full of magic
things patiently waiting for our senses
to grow sharper this is what Yates wrote
or the poet needs the other world the
dream world we long for is this world
rightly seen magical realism is simply
this world rightly seen it can be like
the film Amelie we can literally make
our Lives song we can become poetry so
if you're feeling cynical in the throngs
of Despair living a life of quiet
desperation drudgering away in
unconsciousness in the default setting
in the rat race in that constant gnawing
sense of having hadn't lost some
infinite thing as David Foster Wallace
wrote no news friends the promised land
the the pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow it's all there for the taking if
you open your eyes and understand the
protocols and procedures for boarding up
magical realism right so wrong is proof
that the human race is greater than it
knows right Cinema is truth 24 times per
second move beyond naive realism and go
into the realm of ecstatic truth of
literature of poetry and song and
Friends
like the greatest moments of your life
that no doubt you've known so well that
first kiss that moment when somebody
moved you to the point of Tears when
something's somewhere incredible waiting
to be known was finally seen and you
were like ah more of this you will know
what's possible and you know what I'm
talking about and so that friends is
what I want to leave you with like don't
don't Brew
don't don't don't dismiss don't grow old
don't grow cynic don't lose the faith
don't lose the plot friends don't lose
the blood for the world is magic things
patiently waiting for our senses to grow
sharper and there's a literally a field
of possibility a possibility space at
the doorstep of every moment ready to be
seized in a kind of ecstatic Absolution
and deep play and improvisational
theater and dance and song and art and
Truth
the truth that sets us free the truth
from which nothing can dislodge us
catalepsis the Greece call it this
is what is possible this is magical
realism and this
is what we're here to do
is what we're here to do
it's what we're here
so there you go I mean that pretty much
sums up the message I want to leave you
guys there with you know
just like why the [ __ ] not right
I mean why not like just push at the
edges
so I guess we're pretty much out of time
right so
well thank you guys for listening and as
we move into this cyberdelic age let us
render our dreams into being and let us
take that imagination and have it summon
its own literalization thank you guys so
much and thank you Jimmy
[Applause]